March Madness is beginning we're doing
the brackets tomorrow night
Martinez starts you may nail them on the
Elam what should weekend intern read
should he come in he's a basketball okay
you know and he wants us doing March
Madness brackets yeah read is interested
in on our bracketology do you want to do
bracketology Jim I do yeah I'll nail
this real quick your glasses look good
they don't here's the great thing about
your glasses they don't make you look
older like this they don't but when I do
this they do that's perfect read you're
interested in do my glasses make me look
older Yeah right yeah now you're looking
a gen Xer youthful that's perfect oh boy
you like bracketology yeah I just told
Travis we should do one Ryan raspberry
plans we do we do it's very important
that we get down to the bottom of who is
gonna win cows the number one because
March Madness for those that don't know
it determines the number one basketball
owners of the colleges of the world
yeah it really it's like it's like the
hoopsters Super Bowl yeah it is it is
for colleges yeah and you only know that
it's a college thing if you're super
kind of into it inside sports guy I'm
kind of a what I call them like a like a
sports junkie you know that's me not for
sports for come yeah that's where yes
yeah you know I think Duke's got a very
good chance of winning the games because
they have the good player Zion right
yeah they have a couple actually him
everybody got a couple everybody's
talking about the one player he's
literally the one player anybody's ever
talking about you're not wrong is his
teammate were probably the second pick
so that's the worries that point out
okay but let's not get too deep into
this thing we're talking about Zion yes
that guy is ridiculous he's the one who
ripped his shoes cuz he's so good right
yeah that's he if he once he makes the
NBA he'll be the second heaviest in the
league like in terms of weight yeah and
next guy now is that what you like him
so much
oh yeah like when I was a kid I was four
all fatties the Jackie Robinson for
thick people I see when I was growing up
I I mean I didn't even watch basketball
but if I had to pick a player I liked
Mugsy Bo
because I was short and so is Mugsy that
was his whole deal 19 remember I never
watched him score not one point but he
was my favorite
mine was Magic Johnson you liked him
after the retirement though so the way I
like Mugsy and Jim like magic you like
well my favorite players to weigh in
wait is he heavy no is he good yes he's
not bad
d-wade Dewayne I'd see ya you know I'd
you're if you're a sports junk junk
jockey now it comes like a junkie what's
fanatic I listen yeah I'm kind of a
sports fanatic and I'm Dwight Howard fan
now you like to write Howard now I do
why is that
oh just just all of a sudden joy is
playing I see well so I think I think
Duke NCCN da KST yes too many letters
yeah I'd say that gonna go to Duke
that's a Duke nice to do that one down
the Duke er I'm gonna go to Duke
although Duke has lost I'm gonna go the
next page is VCU and UCF I mean I think
for me it's it's a no-brainer UCF are
you more of a VCU guy right now it's a
UCF okay I'm gonna go UCF as well UCF
I'm going to VCU oh that's very
controversial Liberty misstate yes ah I
see oh you knew miss state stood for
Mississippi State yeah you really watch
this stuff huh yeah no it's give me miss
Tate yeah he's playing possum he
actually studying all year all right I
probably think it's gonna be miss state
as well I'm Virginia Tech against st.
Louis ah that's gotta be Virginia Tech
I'm gonna go st. Louis okay a st. Louis
is my team you know why people say they
go I live in st. Louis misery instead of
money so that's why I go with st. Louis
on that one why don't you meet me in st.
Louis Louie I used to sing that a lot as
a kid mrs. Jones's music class they abot
the team probably go home and suck a
dick oh it's funny because it's true
oh yeah I bet the team probably sings
that before games yeah so that actually
goes to me Marylander against who Bella
or Belmont or temple I like the name
Marilyn better I'll put them
I'm gonna put them because you know
between Belmont and temple they can't
even figure out which one of those trees
going in by the way we go to the bottom
right for a second Seton Hall against
Albin a Seton Hall on a put way they're
not playing Albany they're playing
Wofford oh sorry
Oh petit Hall anyway okay why'd you go
there I'm just bored with going in the
same order so I want to you want to
spice it up Kentucky against that
Kentucky ID so let's go all over the
place now yeah I don't know why you just
went to the bottom manner what's the
difference because we're all doing it
together I know we're jumping around
let's jump around like it's fun and then
you just went to another thing we were
like what the [ __ ] we start in the
middle actually Iowa State against Ohio
you go now you're going from the bottom
up yeah
Iowa State against Ohio State I oh oh
okay Iowa now the one right below that
Houston is exhausting yeah or Georgia
Street I think Georgia Georgia
I'm gonna go Houston okay I'm going with
Georgia and by the way to go back to the
bottom I'm going with Seton Hall and
I'll go into the same thing as you
Kentucky sure let's go to the bottom
left oh yeah
Michigan against Montana number two
against number 15 Michigan don't call
for an upset Montana now is that Joe
Montana University no Hannah okay Hannah
Montana
we have Nevada against Florida right
above that well think about it this
Florida yeah before it is so humid oh my
god why they're gonna win because and
Nevada is the dry heat and their eyes
get dry more things to do in Florida
distract them though oh there's not to
do in Vegas gambling and hookers it's a
good point goose you right yeah I'm
young naive read in the guys aren't 21
such a wholesome boy I'm going to Nevada
still what do you think Texas Tech or
North Kentucky sure both on one of them
yeah yeah I'm gonna pick North Kentucky
not Texas Tech okay what about a buffalo
a bunch of letters I'm gonna go with the
letters
I'm gonna go st. John Hayes est you're
going with Arizona State yeah okay I'm
going st. John let's go somewhere else
where should we go next top right
Virginia against g1e where we gotta go
Virginia in this one I'm gonna say gee
Webb cuz it sounds like a rapper oh yes
sure it does so I like G Webb
Ole Miss against Oklahoma I hate the
name Ole Miss I'm gonna go with Oklahoma
I'm gonna go with Oklahoma cuz roll tide
write read no that's not is say I think
it's it I think that that's right
where to next Wisconsin Oregon well
there was car the Buckeyes yeah
against the Orient the Oregon hoopsters
I'm gonna go with the the Oregon
hoopsters I'm gonna go with the Buckeyes
I think know that they were kind of
farty it selected Wisconsin
yeah but Wisconsin's not the but that's
their the Badgers I think the Buckeyes
about this let's go right below that
okay the Kansas State wheat Huskers
against the the UC UC Irvine clouds I'm
gonna go with the clouds Yerevan with
the Kansas Street wheat Huskers okay so
we're going different on that one
okay Villanova versus st. Mary's I'm
gonna tell you you know what we called
Villanova when I was in Syracuse what
Villa no fun
so that's chill I gotta go st. Mary's
where's that that's right under right
under our last one Villanova or Saint
Mary's no now I'm gonna go with the
ville anova manova preachers
okay what about i i'd say in the battle
of in the in the battle of purdue versus
Old Dominion I think Old Dominion is
actually a little too old yeah I think
so to know their little watch that is
though little washed up I'm gonna go
with Purdue and I'll tell you why
because I eat the chicken all the time
yeah the Purdue jump or something to go
with yeah yeah and they get up high do
you want to go over to the other side of
the shore you just finish that okay now
the LSU against Yale
Yale is the smartest school go yeah now
yell it's a bunch of [ __ ] nerds I'm
gonna go LSU plus the cheating to get
into Yale everybody don't aunt Becky's
daughters playing on the Yale Yale's
basketball team I think so no oh yeah
okay Louisville against Minnesota I'm
gonna have to go with Minnesota because
I think Louisville is really stupid name
okay and Jesse Ventura Minnesota that
makes sense yeah yeah he's tall he sure
is Michigan State and Bradley my dad
went to Michigan State so I would think
Michigan State will win
I'm gonna go with Michigan State 2-1
Gonzaga against 16 purdue pube padieu
pew dog is ranked number one there's
four number one teams you but yeah and
that breath that's stupid
yeah all right we'll go with baby
we'll go Gonzaga you know why it's a fun
name yeah sure it's fun to say
see recuse against bail or clearly
Syracuse now I'm gonna go with Baylor
too right cool your excuse put out a
bunch of garbage that's not true and
that's entirely now let's go to
Marquette State yeah Murray can talk to
Murray State Buckeyes I'm gonna go with
going Buckeyes yeah I'm gonna go with
the Murray Street Buckeyes I'm gonna go
with Marquette okay Vermont and Florida
State uh she the Vermont syrups
I'm gonna go Vermont yeah me Sanders
that's right well no and everybody loses
in Vermont that would mean Iowa wait
Iowa against CIN CIN ah Cincinnati I'm
gonna go with Iwerks I hate Cincinnati
I'm going Cincinnati because I hate Iowa
okay the next one is our Colgate against
Tennessee let's go Colgate of course a
much better for your mouth you're much
better North Carolina against Iona
that's easy Iona that is fun it's fun to
say what's it's in the best Chester I
own an apartment that's all mine I own a
hat that's so great Travis I I own is in
the best Chester but people in the best
not to lose ours we are the best teams
yeah come on I'm gonna go to North
Carolina Reed convinced me I'm going
Iona because yeah but why would they
call the best why would they call
Westchester the best Chester if they
lost okay but how's this Roy were the
the Henry Orbison no I was being called
does Roy Orbison play for Iona even more
reason no I own it a head coach for you
in let's go what do you think you toss
my arrow for everyone's what you just
saying words man hammer accurately form
a sentence don't open your memory you
know
hammering okay you just ramble what do
you think
Troy do you understand a word that's
coming out of that boy's mouth nonsense
yeah I don't either
it's literally just foolish I'll try not
to cut anyone off
Utah State or Washington where everybody
knows Utah already is a state so
Washington all right we'll go watch them
and then the final two battles in the
first round no yep is albarn against
North next I'm gonna go we'll all burn
I mean senators been hoping I'm gonna go
north Mexico okay and the next one is
Kansas against northeastern everybody
knows well I think I corns over the
monuments I'm gonna go with Kansas I
don't know I think it may be the
northeastern Nor'easters oh cool I'm
gonna go northeastern because it's a
whole area of the country it's not just
one state you know that's a lot to have
to pick a choose from sure okay you want
to move to the sweet 16
I don't like bored at this I know it's
so much but I mean to start with how
many people do they start with 16 I got
em all I was it all a paper 68 different
schools it's too many read it's a good
amount
no one's ever picked all of them right I
I did last year I know Warren Buffett
offered what do you offer a million he
did Travis do you still have my bat my
ballot thing from last year no what do I
keep Sam things like accepted a piece of
paper either probably I do that
electronically I'll never know all right
I'm gonna say Duke over UCF I'm gonna
say st. Louie going to UCF I'm gonna go
with yeah I'll go with Duke I'm gonna go
do st. Louis over Mississippi no I'm
gonna give it a wait which one did I say
who's playing in the next one I've
written it down oh I wrote them down
yeah so we were just over jigna Tech I'm
gonna go Maryland over Yale cuz I have a
good body that went to Maryland that's
you know you go I have LSU someone ago
they lost you cuz I hate your friends
okay Michigan State over Minnesota
because my dad went to Michigan State I
have Minnesota Michigan State I'm gonna
go at Minnesota come on dad because his
[ __ ] bothers me I see
Syracuse over Gonzaga obviously and Zog
against who do I have their bail or I'm
gonna go with Baylor Murray State over
Vermont because Kentucky is a hell of a
town yeah
Vermont okay st. John I'll do st. John
over Kentucky I don't know what I have
here I can't read my writing so I'm just
gonna put the Texas Tech okay that's
smart and I'm gonna go to Minnesota you
got to go with Florida cuz they practice
more okay Minnesota Minnesota is not on
that whatever it is I put forth the
matter right I'm writing are gonna vada
Virginia Oklahoma I have G web and I'm
gonna have G web continuing I'm gonna go
with Oklahoma cuz G web is sounds like a
rapper or again against Kansas I have
Wisconsin against Ervin I'm gonna go
Wisconsin I'll go with Kansas I'm gonna
go Oregon now Villanova Purdue of course
Lee no fun yeah you gotta go with Purdue
I'm gonna say Purdue over st. Mary the
chicken Iowa against Villanova Colgate
uh you gotta go with Iowa I have
Cincinnati and Colgate I'm gonna go
Colgate no there are a lot of Washington
Purdue and Colgate chicken vs.
toothpaste that's [ __ ] great isn't it
great they work well together
North Carrington I'm gonna go with you
upset Washington I have Iona going over
Washington Iona's making it to the sweet
16 because the best Chester Auburn's
Kansas is gonna be wall burns
come again their secondaries been
playing well I'm gonna say northeastern
goes all the way to the sweet 16 they're
Iowa Houston Iowa I have Iowa over
Georgia and now what's this I can't do
it that says Seton Hall hip seat Hall
all I see no I have Kentucky beating
Seton Hall I guess II know we're done no
no now we got to get to the Elite Eight
gym Oh every number we do just have to
cut it in half
oh yeah no word I know it's very Boris
is hating this what a bonus time anyway
what he means bonus I think you're
hating it and just deflecting oh it's
almost 10 o'clock okay people who like
March Madness are they like our Sports
Picks that are cool because people a lot
of people tune in for our sports
expertise right Reid no I do for sure
that's what attracted you to the show
initial exactly I get the most knowledge
in this short amount time now Reid do
you have your your brackets or
bracketology is about the same as ours I
wasn't I know this isn't my
well-thought-out bracket version I kind
of just do it
off the fly like you guys but no you
might as well thought out
I'm gonna finish mine real quick okay
what do you got I got Duke in st. Louis
I'm gonna say st. Louis I'm going with
Duke and you go Duke and then LSU
against Minnesota LSU I got Michigan
State over Maryland because your dad
went there my dad went there baver Mont
I'll go with Bay I got Syracuse beating
Murray stayed in and then Tito in
Florida will go with TT I got st. John
beating Nevada Oh Kansas City Kansas
City I got G Webb beating Wisconsin to
Iowa
Purdue chicken I gotta do beating
Colgate Washington Auburn's the Auburn's
I got a own a beating northeastern cuz
best chest Iowa Seton Hall the Seton
Hall errs I got Kentucky beating Iowa
now the Final Four the Final Four Duke
LSU LSU it's can be a big upset I got
Michigan State Baylor TT Baylor hang on
I got Michigan State over st. Louis
Kansas Purdue it's gonna be Purdue I got
Syracuse over Saint John and then I got
to get Seton Hall it's gonna be Seton
Hall now here's the final I got Purdue
over G Webb if Purdue goin when they do
the chicken I know I get that okay so
let's let's all go over our final read
what's your final four I haven't got a
LSU Baylor don't give us your final yet
just stay with the final four Seton Hall
I'm gonna go to Michigan North Carolina
and Villanova
I've got Michigan State Syracuse Purdue
and Iona you have Michigan State because
your dad Syracuse that's where I went
Purdue it's the same name as the chicken
company and I own it is in the best
Chester yeah and I'm gonna do Syracuse
over Michigan State because at the end
of the day let's be honest I am better
than my dad
I got LSU and I got Iona over Perdue
because the best Chester and I got Seton
Hall oh what a battle LSU signal
I have Syracuse and Iona in the national
NCAA Championship of basketball I got
Seton Hall winning at all feel like
yours a little bit biased what to the
best yes hey you yeah so see your Hall
is your big winner billion dollars
coming up Warren do we million dollars
you know not we should guess the
combined score to what you do is yeah I
did that was I couldn't like 100 points
I guessed it correctly one years I put
it behind in 79 well I'll do 179 know I
won 5-2 hurt I feel like I won 5-2
okay I haven't picked my winner yet but
I'm going 179 points one could rob were
you doing a bracketology - yes
who's your national championship game I
got the the dukey's against jigna cool
and who wins the dukey's CI a-- duke
getting knocked out in the sweet 16 st.
Louis I don't I don't know why I pick
st. Louis to beat them well st. Louis is
a it's a strong thirteen you've got a
strong thirty it's a strong 13 seed so
you never know and what's your
championship game Reed duke-north
Carolina and who do you have in the
championship who do you have winning the
whole thing Duke and who you have
winning the whole thing I have Duke who
do you think's better Syracuse or Iona
Syracuse meet you yeah because I went
there so did I own is not really a
powerhouse so no whoa whoa yes it is
from the V it's from the best chair on
the bracket with a powerhouse okay
they're not one of the teams where it's
one or the other like they don't have to
win a game to get into the bracket
they're already in the bracket yeah that
means they're they're already better
than you just told me there were too
many teams it is it's too many bound to
be a few bad teams Jennifer I really
like gyms Seton Hall pick yeah it is a
good gym D and you picked what was the
combined sweet haulers and the final
scores get 152 and mine's 179 let me
write my name on it
where'd you get that number of rotation
179 it's from my experience as a
basketball man I got you Obama
I'm gonna go prices right 178 cool I
played I played in Syracuse you did yes
I did I was a walk-on yeah man I was
actually quite good Wow yeah that's why
Carmelo Anthony was like I'm not saying
on this team if Sam's gonna be here he's
sure outshining me absolutely yeah here
you go
new emoji bugs I was I was the mo I know
I wasn't at all this start tomorrow
night yeah yeah yeah the Bucs will start
rolling in
oh yeah and Reed why don't you well now
why don't you start giving us a report
on how we're all doing in the Final Four
you know anymore
I want they'd like you to be responsible
for this data Rob will help you
obviously the road to the Final Four
we mean the road to oh the journey it's
not all called the Final Four yes the
road
the final so when there's 64 teams they
don't just say like let's start the
final four no no they say let's start
the road to the Final Four the journey
the journey it's all along the road yeah
yeah so then you keep us on reading you
let us know how everybody's doing but I
have a prediction that both Jim and
myself are gonna do I already know how
it's gonna go so yeah so you you wanna
make history so yours are less
predictions and more spoilers yeah you
think you're gonna get a billion dollars
you watch I get all the right in the
score I'm gonna be headline news all
over the world will you share any of the
money we get what are you gonna do with
it if I donate it to what I call the
come fund that's a big jar